i'm going to ask you what you want to
hear a rap about and the two women over
there are excited the rest of you uh
think of the word of a topic or a phrase
you would like to hear a wrap about
there are one second one
[Music]
no food no animals nothing too boring
the best suggestion ever was a german
man who said a day is a life of an aztec
high priest
so we'll get we'll get some suggestions
and uh someone over there said feet is
pretty simple so why don't you expand on
that with some adjectives
it means describing words
anyone else can help
[Music]
[Music]
know it's not like we take the word foot
and then add five adjectives and go
around
you're still when you're sitting on the
train
on a train
a foot
a human foot this
on a tray are you thinking of a shoe
finding a dirty slimy foot on a train
hammer toes uh what do i wrap up middle
of the room no more feet
yeah you hate him now you just
yeah and people over here try and be
better than all these terrible people
queen elizabeth the first of the second
the
[Laughter]
i am this close to not doing
the finale of the show
i hate you all right so it's
it's a freestyle rap that's around made
up on the spot based entirely on
suggestions
let's remind ourselves because we've got
a hammertoe a dirty slimy nasty foot
found on a train queen elizabeth queen
elizabeth's feet and aids
and let's try and do this [ __ ]
you're laughing arms cross lady beside
you like why are you talking about
immunodeficiency virus acquiring a
deficiency syndrome
devastated i'm in san francisco a whole
generation gay men
[Music]
sorry to me take the night nasty like
sucking on a fever who's it only look
down below i'm like what's the deal with
your nasty toe oh i don't really
understand or i wanna stay there stop it
like mc hammer get it stop
[Music]
you were like yo chris get this in your
brain imagine this you just be sitting
on a train you're like oh
here's my ticket what do i wanna do a
feet just kick it why is it loose over
there walking i can see metatarsal bones
and
is
[Music]
i would like to get the blade on my
shoulder like a knife i saw her in a
bedroom in the middle of the night that
really happened 22 years ago remember
this didn't happen maybe covered up i
can't prove there and when he's finished
shed in all the blood he was like stop
lizzy and start having a rub oh yes
she's like prince phil you're so large
and he made blood but after giving her a
foot massage
you